le scénario semble tout droit tirée d'un
film était 2017 alexandre case un jeune
trifluvienne de 25 ans est arrêtée de
façon spectaculaire à bangkok en
thaïlande
une semaine plus tard il est retrouvé
mort en prison dans des circonstances
pour le moins troubles grâce à une fuite
de données sans précédent baptisé
pandora p2 les décrypteurs ont obtenu
des documents inédits qui lève le voile
sur le réseau opéré par alexandre case
une structure complexe où transitaient
des sommes immenses d'argent illicites
sous le radar des autorités
jeff quelle histoire incroyable
commençons par le personnage principal
qui était alexandre case donc sur la
surface c'était un jeune homme de 25 ans
québécois capteurs en thaïlande qui
avait une entreprise de marketing web
donc qui offrait ses services de
marketing sans club après son
arrestation et son décès ce qu'on a
appris c'est que en faillite le
gestionnaire d'alphabet le plus gros
marché légal de l'histoire du web doc si
vous connaissez ib un site où on peut
vendre et acheter des choses d'un
alphabet c'était sauf pour de la
marchandise illégale donc on peut
acheter de la drogue on peut acheter du
matériel pour faire de la fraude on
pouvait acheter des armes à feu et
alexandre quasi tel gestionnaire de ce
site web le il prélevait en deux à
quatre pour cent de toutes les
transactions qui est venu sur ce site
web le beaucoup d'argent avec van damme
américains estiment qu'ils avaient en
600 mille huit cent mille dollars de
ventes chaque jour effectuée sur ce site
là donc après son arrestation on a
appris qu'il y avait une fortune
personnelle quand même ainsi que
considérable plusieurs maisons un en
thaïlande dans d'autres pays des autos
de luxe et ceux qui avaient vraiment
fait les manchettes ces cons on s'est
rendu compte que cet homme-là qui gérent
c'est illégal avait une fortune
personnelle que le bon américain estimé
à 30 millions de dollars canadiens ok ça
c'est ce qu'on savait ce qu'ils avaient
à la surface mais tout obtenu des
documents qui nous permettent d'en
savoir plus sur sa façon de procéder et
où décrypteurs on a participé aux
pandores uppers qu'une immense fuites de
documents internes de firmes qui offre
des services d'incorporation outre-mer
donc on parle de 12 millions de
documents provenant de quatorze filles
la plus grosse fuite de documents de
cette période de l'histoire est-ce qu'on
ait fourni ces documents ainsi
qu'alexandre case avait une structure
corporative outre-mer dont il y avait au
minimum six entreprises déduction avec
des entreprises écran à son nom il ya
peu utilisé une de ses compagnes écran
pour acheter illégalement maison talent
les étrangers ont pas le droit d'acheter
des maisons en thaïlande on sait aussi
que utiliser ces compagnies cran pour
s'acheter la citoyenneté dans au moins
deux pays dont kantigui barbade et à
chypre île selon le département de la
justice américaine il recherchait a
acheté la citoyenneté au moins six pays
donc quelque chose on en convient d'
assez utile pour un cybercriminel
d'avoir est souhaitée dans plusieurs
pays ce qui est encore plus intéressant
des documents c'est que après son décès
le gouvernement américain or saisi tous
ses biens dont ses compagnes et craint
mais il ya d'autres compagnies écran qui
semble ne pas avoir détecté ces
compagnies les écrans l'heure n'était
pas aux noms d'alexandre case il était
le propriétaire
ultime mais son nom n'apparaissait pas
dans les registres
cyber criminels qui a profité donc de
systèmes qui existent un peu parallèle
mais qui pose pas de question qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec ce genre de phénomène la
commande l'encadrent que faire mais
exactement j'ai parlé à des experts en
matière de fiscalité
justement de la fiscalité du crime ce
qu'on dit compagnie cran comme ça où le
nom de la personne qui le propriétaire
n'apparaît pas ça pose problème ça
permet de faire toutes sortes de choses
notre hamas de blanchir de l'argent donc
un indeco classique de blanchiment
d'argent c'est justement d'acheter des
propriétés
parce que on achète la propriété avec
une compagnie écran et quand on la vend
la provenance de l'argent vient de la
propriété et non des activités légales
au vu des banques donc ça permet de
prendre son argent illégal qui est de la
mettre dans l'économie légitime en
achetant une maison donc des biens de
luxe comme ça des maisons des voitures
de course de l'ordre des choses comme ça
c'est des choses qui convoie ccdcoe
classique dans le blanchiment d'argent
donc les experts ce qu'ils nous ont dit
c'est que le problème fondamental c'est
que il faut forcer tous les registres
d'entreprises partout dans le monde non
seulement montré le président de la
compagnie parce que si on peut inscrire
un prête-nom pour agir à titre de
président mais le propriétaire de la
compagnie pour voir si acquis à partir
vraiment les actifs de cette compagnie
entre une chose est certaine jeff saviez
braquer les projecteurs sur ce type de
stratagème j'avais tout le monde à les
lire ton article pour comprendre ça avec
un peu plus de détails et de profondeur
c'est sur la page web des décrypteurs
est le corollaire aussi de toute cette
histoire c'est qu'avec alexandre caser
son histoire à lui on s'est mis
médiatiquement balle canada francophone
a parlé soudainement beaucoup plus du
dark web le commun des mortels ne
navigue pas sur le dark web
si on utilise l'image d'un iceberg pour
illustrer internet le web fréquenté par
le grand public serait la partie hors de
l'eau le dark web la pointe inférieure
dans les eaux chaudes profonde et moins
fréquenté ni que la parole d'un kwh m
j'ai comme l'impression que ce terme là
cette notion là elle est utilisée à tort
et à travers médiatiquement est ce qu on
a vraiment bien cerner le concept le
dorze web un réseau parallèle
complètement différent auquel on peut
seulement accéder grâce à des programmes
spécifiques
donc ces programmes là il en existe
plusieurs le le plus connu ses torts
tort c'est comme un navigateur web qui
nous donne accès à des sites web du dark
web spécifique le et c'est un darknet
qu'on appelle ça donc et plusieurs
d'entre net différentes or le plus
populaire et les sites du dark knight or
termine avec l'extension point oignons
pourquoi n'y aux oignons donc un oignon
parce que plus un couche de chiffrement
plusieurs couches de sécurité
différentes à ces sites webs donc avec
cette idée d'oignons et de thor c'est
pas une ligne directe et plusieurs
chemins pour arriver un but précis c'est
ça donc plutôt qu'envoyer ces données
directement un site ça passe par
plusieurs serveurs donc c'est ça les
couches de chiffrement le sait plusieurs
savoir vers lequel passent l'information
de manière chiffrée de manière en crypté
et quand ça arrive à destination mais
ces informations leur sont déchiffrer
mais pour le commun des mortels si le
personnes se lèvent le matin puis il
veut voir de ses propres yeux ce à quoi
ça ressemble dans les clubs à travers
l'outil le navigateur tort comme on fait
comment ça marche c'est super simple je
peux te le montrer jamais un ordinateur
pour pour l'occasion ça tombe bien dans
l'autre et ça est-ce qu'on louve c'est
ça sera vraiment de notre 14 comme tous
les autres pour accéder au site par
contre il faut savoir où est ce qu'on
s'en va céder adresse un peu plus
compliqué qu'une adresse web normal
c'est souvent une séquence de chiffres
de lettres un peu aléatoire le joli sur
fb master est un marché un peu comme
ebay comme n'importe quel autre marché
en ligne et là plusieurs comme ce qui
existe sur le web je regarde je peux
acheter des drogues si je veux l'on peut
regarder mon les opioïdes par exemple
fait qu'il ya vingt-trois 23 produits en
vente différents il ya le pays si dans
une crypte aux monnaies puis on peut
voir le sait comme n'importe quel autre
marché en ligne vraiment on peut voir
les différents vendeurs ont décrite ci
l'ont le voit ici des drogues illicites
je vois toutes sortes de services qui
sont offerts il ya de la fraude aussi
qui est passé mais espère que ça qui est
disponible sur ce genre de résoudre d'un
coup une étude qui a été faite en 2016
nous indique que 60 % des sites oignons
les 60% des sets sur terre sont utilisés
à des fins illicites une fois proportion
une fois de probation c'est ce test est
non exhaustive comme études mais quand
même par contre une autre étude qui a
été faite l'an dernier que nous qui nous
montre que seulement 7% des utilisateurs
de thor s'en servent à des fins
illégales donc toutes sortes d'autres
raisons pour lesquelles on peut se
servir de ce que ce soit dans un pays où
il ya de la censure de l'internet donc
avec ce d'aviateur là on procède et
c'est oignons mais aussi à des sites web
normes ou de manière sécurisée donc si
on est censuré si le web bloqués dans
notre pays on peut servir de tour il ya
même des lanceurs d'alert qui peuvent
communiquer avec radio canada à travers
ce genre de raison exactement mais
radio-canada une plateforme secure du
rap qui a été développé pour plusieurs
médias ça se passe via torse et pas sur
le web normal que ça se fait justement
pour les raisons pour la sécurité
supplémentaire que ça nous a alors ça
pose tout problème de qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec un réseau comme celui-là on y
connaît parce que autant pour des
raisons évidentes certains voudraient le
banner avec les activités criminelles
qui s'y retrouvent autant il ya d un
aspect bénéfique à tout ça il est le
dilemme c'est un peu le même débat qu'on
a depuis toujours le de du chiffrement
versus la protection de la sécurité
publique vie privée versus sécurité
publique mais je pense que comme
d'habitude ce débat là c'est très sympa
noir et blanc c'est un couteau à double
tranchant puis je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup d'aspects positifs face à
autant que des deux côtés sombres la
criminalité etc donc
il n'ya pas de réponse facile mais je
pense qu'en bout de ligne l'internet sa
a été créée quand même pour avoir toute
cette liberté là c'est quand même
fondamentalement une belle chose que ça
existe tellement un côté sombre associe
donc c'est difficile de trancher là
dessus